-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to another
attic show without tacos.
And I say without tacos.
Because that's an anagram
for addict shows.
And personally, I think coming
up with anagrams
is a fun way to pass time
during a pandemic --
denim cap,
which is a good one
because maybe the only thing
worse than wearing
a denim cap is going
through a pandemic. See?
Aren't anagrams more fun than
baking a loaf of sour dough
or noon day rye, which is an
anagram for Andy Rooney,
who I realize I'm starting
to sound like.
Have you ever noticed how
anagrams are just
the same letters
in a different order?
But look, I'm not here to talk
about Portland mud.
I'm here to talk
about Donald Trump.
Because the president
and his political allies are,
once again, trying to subvert
the 2020 election,
sue it the 2020 convertible
by using the levers of power
to target political opponents
and disrupt
the voting process, itself.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look.
♪♪
Donald Trump is a deranged man.
We have been over this.
You guys know the deal.
If this show were a book,
that would be the subtitle.
His brain is likely
the gelatinous texture
and consistency
of pumpkin pie filling,
and there is no way
to treat a brain ailment
like that, though,
I guess we're going to find out
if hydroxychloroquine helps.
Trump is a deeply paranoid guy
who sees enemies
and shadowy plots
everywhere he looks.
And he encourages others to see
those same conspiracies.
On Tuesday, for example,
he met with farmers
and told the potato farmer
from Virginia
that the state government
was somehow trying
to take away
the Second Amendment.
-We're going after Virginia
with your crazy governor.
We're going after Virginia.
They want to take
your Second Amendment away,
you know that right?
You will have nobody
guarding your potatoes.
-I have been in quarantine
for two months with two kids
and I still haven't said
anything that crazy.
You know that farmer
was like, "Oh, damn.
am I supposed to be guarding
my potatoes right now?"
You know what's guarding
your potatoes,
the fact that they cost
about 12 cents a pound
and grow underground.
Of course, Trump probably
thinks potatoes grow in bags
on supermarket shelves.
I'm just kidding.
He's never been
to a supermarket.
But that's how Trump's
mind works.
He sees deranged
conspiracies everywhere.
Take voting.
We like to think of it
as perhaps
the single most sacred principle
underpinning our democracy.
Voting is a universal right,
not a privilege.
Even the Republican Party,
which has for decades committed
itself to suppressing the votes
of marginalized people
through voter I.D. laws
and gerrymandering,
knows enough to at least pay
lip service to that idea.
But on Wednesday,
as is his want,
Trump just blurted out the truth
during an incoherent rant
on mail-in voting.
He sees voting as an honor,
not a right.
-I think just common sense
would tell you
that it's massive manipulation
can take place.
Massive.
And you do, you have cases
of fraudulent ballots
where they actually print them
and they give them
to people to sign.
Maybe the same person
signs them
with different writing,
different pens.
I don't know.
A lot of things can happen.
Now, if you can,
you should go and vote.
Voting is an honor.
It shouldn't be something
where they send you
a pile of stuff
and you send it back.
-They send you a pile of stuff
That's mail.
That's how the mail works.
Now you go to a restaurant
and send chicken to a stranger
you've never met,
and the next thing you know
they bring it to you on a plate.
It makes no sense.
You know, voter fraud
is virtually
non-existent in this country.
The most famous recent example
with a voter fraud scheme
concocted by Republicans
to cheat in an
Congressional election
in North Carolina in 2018,
which invalidated the election
and resulted in a redo.
Now, you might be wondering
if Democratic voter fraud
is so supposedly widespread
as Republicans claim,
why do we only know
about voter fraud cases
involving Republicans?
MSNBC asked
the then executive director
of the North Carolina GOP
that question,
and he did not have
a particularly good answer.
-We constantly are hearing
Republicans say
that Democrats are engaged
in voter fraud.
There is almost never any
evidence of that,
and right here you're holding
a board that has at least
22 cases of voter fraud
in the state of North Carolina
and executed by Republicans
in one district.
-In one Congressional district
on one election.
-So, 22 cases of voter fraud
by a Republican.
Where are the Democratic
cases of voter fraud?
-Well -- well, I-I-I'm not
keeping score of that.
-Well -- well -- well, it looks
like you caught me
with my britches down,
but as you have insulted
my honor, I have
no recourse but to challenge
you a dual tomorrow morning
in the potato field.
And yet yesterday,
Trump threatened on Twitter
to unilaterally withhold funding
from the states of Michigan
and Nevada simply
for mailing out applications
for absentee ballots,
which is perfectly legal
in which states with Democratic
and Republican governors
have done for years.
Just five months, after he got
impeached for threatening
to withhold funding
from Ukraine
unless they
interfere in the election.
In two months after he said
governors who want help
from the federal government
have to treat him well,
he keeps using the same move
over and over.
It's only a matter of time
before he threatens to withhold
funding from the post office,
unless they promise to look at
every ballot and dump the ones
marked for Biden in the shredder
he uses for his tax returns.
It comes
with an extra large bin.
And the Republican party
is fully
in lock step
behind Trump.
In the middle of a pandemic
that has killed more
than 90,000 Americans
and created the economy,
they're transforming the Senate
into an arm
of the Presidents' campaign.
The Senate Judiciary Committee,
led by Lindsey Graham
is moving forward
with an investigation
of the origins
of the Russia probe in an effort
to target Obama administration
officials in the Senate
Homeland Security
and Governmental Affairs
Committee led by Ron Johnson
who voted to subpoena documents
as part of an investigation
of Hunter Biden.
The same investigation Trump
got impeached for,
and Republicans
are fine with all of it.
You might get a little grumble,
you know, from Mitt Romney
and Susan Collins
might form a committee
to look into the possibility
of furrowing her brow.
But otherwise the GOP
is done with all of it.
They're like bank robbers
who get caught planning a heist
and then say,
"Should we do it anyway?"
Republicans are just as paranoid
and conspiratorial as Trump.
He didn't come out of nowhere.
He fits perfectly in the GOP.
They've concocted
an insane fantasy
in which Obama spied on Trump
by secretly monitoring
suspicious calls
by Michael Flynn
and not telling Trump about it,
as Johnson claimed Tuesday
on Fox News.
-So if that were the case,
that they were genuinely
concerned that there was some
compromise or something
going on, it was nefarious
on those phone calls,
why would they have not told
the incoming
President of the United States?
-Because it's a corrupt
transition process.
You know, it's exactly
what they should have done.
-They did.
This isn't secret.
Obama warned then
President-elect Trump
about Flynn during a meeting
in the oval office
two days after the election.
I mean, do you remember?
That incredibly bizarre meeting
where Trump sat stone-faced
next to Obama like a terrified
seventh grader
who just got called into
the principal's office?
These guys have concocted
a bunch
of insane conspiracy theories.
Now they're using the levers
of the government
to suppress votes
and drum up politically
motivated investigation,
and they're doing that
because they're losing.
Polls show Americans broadly
dissatisfied with Trump's
handling of the pandemic
and Biden
consistently ahead of Trump.
And when a Democrat
is ahead of Trump in the polls,
it's all over, baby.
Oh.
Right.
The President has badly
mishandled the massive
cataclysm that has left
nearly 100,000 Americans dead
and the economy in tatters.
Yet, on Wednesday he insisted
he had actually handled
the situation perfectly.
-Mr. President, with four
percent of the world population
and 30 percent of the outbreak,
what would you
have done differently
facing this crisis?
-Well, nothing.
-Are you sure?
You don't want to think about it
for maybe another second?
You don't think you would have
changed anything
like, you know,
maybe you shouldn't have said
coronavirus would disappear
like a miracle,
that it was like the flu
or that you could cure it
but chopping Tide GO Stiks
and shining a heat lamp
up your ass?
Okay.
In reality, of course,
there are lots of things
we could have been doing
and should be doing now
to suppress the outbreak.
New data reported by
the the "New York Times"
last night suggested
that lockdown delays
cost at least 36,000 lives.
Instead Trump has been obsessed
with pushing hydroxychloroquine
as an unproven miracle cure
despite the fact
that his own FDA
warns against taking it.
Now after claming out of nowhere
that he was taking
hydroxychloroquine,
Trump announced on Wednesday
that he was about to stop.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-I think the regimen
finishes in a day or two.
I think it's a two days.
-So Trump took an unproven drug
for no reason
and decided arbitrarily
the regimen finishes
in a day or two.
Yeah, I only have two days left,
because last I check
there were just the two pills
left in the dispenser.
You better not be holding out
on me, Micky.
The President's pushing
dangerous miracle cures
when there are actually
lots of things, like testing,
contact tracing and isolation
we could doing to save lives.
In fact, this week we have
provided a fairly stark contrast
between things that do work
and things that don't work
in combating
the coronavirus pandemic
and which of those Trump
has chose on the embrace.
For example, there was a polling
this week that experiments
by a team in Hong Kong
found that the coronavirus
transmission rate
via respiratory droplets
or airborne particles
dropped by as much as 75 percent
when surgical masks
were used.
Now,
that's potentially huge news.
However, there is one big caveat
to this story.
The study used hamsters
in two cages.
One group of hamsters
infected with Covid-19
and the other healthy.
Now, if you're wondering
how one group of hamsters
got infected,
they were the hamsters
who violated stay-at-home orders
to get haircuts.
You guys want to know
something fun?
You see whatever
that picture is?
I haven't seen it yet.
You are seeing it before I do.
We just write hamster
with super-styled haircut,
and then a member of our
incredible graphics team
working from their
department makes it.
Then I pretend to look at it
like this.
I'm like...
I'm just --
I'm just staring at
the ceiling in my attic.
I miss being at work, guys.
I'm over this
reacquainting funk.
Also, the study just used
mask barriers in the cages.
They didn't actually make
the hamsters wear masks,
but I really wish they had
because that would mean,
you know,
actually it's someone's
job to make tiny
hamster-sized face masks.
And then from that, we could
extrapolate they also make
hamster-sized accessories like
gloves, you know,
briefcases, tank tops,
baseball helmets.
And, of course, tiny cages
for the pet hamsters
tiny pet hamsters.
Again, I have no idea
what any of those graphics
are gonna look like,
but I assume they're fun.
I hope you enjoy them.
So, this finding is obviously
preliminary
and has some caveats,
but it's consistent
with what we know
about countries
that have adopted widespread
masks wearing along
with other techniques
like contact tracing.
By and large they have a lot
more success containing
the pandemic than we have.
Widespread masks wearing
along with testing,
contact tracing and isolation
is one of a few
simple measures that could
very possibly help us
get back to some semblance
of normalcy.
And yet conservatives have
decided to turn it
into yet another
dumb culture war issue.
Some have even theorized
that it's a media conspiracy
to keep people
permanently afraid.
-Rush Limbaugh made a great
point, as he always does,
on the radio the other day.
And he said the virus itself,
as it weakens
and states start reopening,
the media that have been
selling this panic, panic,
panic, for weeks and weeks
and weeks,
they have fewer images to sell
their hysteria to justify
continued lockdowns.
But the masks, well, they're
kind of a constant reminder.
You see the mask
and you think you're not safe,
you are not back to normal.
Not even close.
-Okay.
First of all, any time someone
says Rush Limbaugh
made a great point
the other day,
that's your cue
to exit the conversation.
That's usually the point
on Thanksgiving
where you excuse yourself,
go to the bathroom
and take a hit off your vape
pen, or alternatively,
look for your vape pen,
realize you forgot it
and frantically search
the medicine cabinet
for something
that will get you high.
Oh, amoxicillin.
I had a potato with it.
Second, you think people
need to see masks
to be reminded
that things are bad?
I assure you,
no one needs to be reminded.
We can't go to the gym.
Our mail is soaked
in so much Lysol
we can barely read
the return address,
and we've been locked
in our houses
with our kids
for three months.
I'm so desperate
to keep my children
entertained, I spent all month
making wasp T-shirts
and then we did not one,
not two, but three takes.
Now they want to
know when their next gig is.
My younger one keeps telling me
he has an agent now,
and given how crazy [bleep] is,
I honestly can't tell
if he is joking or not.
The point is mass wearing
isn't some liberal
media conspiracy.
There is evidence
to suggest it works.
Lots of other countries do it.
The vast majority of Americans
agree with it.
A new poll out on Wednesday
found that 62 percent
of Americans say deciding
to wear a face mask
is more a matter
of public health
than a matter
of personal choice.
About two-thirds say they always
or mostly wear a face mask
or other covering
when they're in public
and near other people,
and 69 percent say that it's
a sign of respectfulness
to wear a face mask
when in public
and near other people.
And they're right.
It's just common decency.
If you know that coughing
or breathing on someone
can get them sick,
you cover your mouth,
unless are you Trump,
in which case you force everyone
to cluster together
next to you
in a tiny briefing room
and repeatedly grab
the microphone like the emcee
at an open mic night.
Is anyone here --
Is anyone here from out of town?
[ Coughs ]
You, sir, In the front room,
front row right there.
Yeah, where are you from?
I know it's you, Fauci.
I know it's you.
Okay.
Can you tell me
where you're from,
so I can burn you
a couple times, Fauci?
Hey, we only -- we only roast
the ones we love,
and I love you, Fauci.
You're my best friend.
And despite the fact that
the CDC recommends it
and most Americans
agree with it,
Trump again to refuse to wear
a mask today while touring
a Ford plant in Michigan
after Ford
had initially said
they would require one.
Trump and Vice President
Mike Pence repeatedly refused
to wear masks in settings
where they were required
or where everyone around them
was wearing one.
But aside the fact
that Trump and Pence
are ignoring their own
government's guidelines
on mask wearing
or the stupid
conservative culture war
over masks,
why do you guys have to be such
dicks about everything?
Just be polite.
If you go over
to someone's house
and they ask you
to take your shoes off,
you take your shoes off.
Then you quietly
make a mental note
that you're not going to any
more of Sharon's game nights.
You don't make a big show
of leaving them on
and tracking mud everywhere,
or in Trump's case,
toilet paper.
There's simple straight
forward things
we could have done
and could be doing now
to suppress the outbreak
and safely get back
to some semblance of normalcy.
Instead, the President
and his allies are spending
their time trying to subvert
the 2020 elections.
They're concocting wild
fantasies about Obama spying
or Democrats committing
voter fraud.
None of that has
any basis in reality.
Soon Trump is going to start
telling people
if he doesn't get re-elected...
You'll have nobody
guarding your potatoes.
-This has been a looser lock.
-Anagram!
♪♪
-During the Covid crisis,
City Harvest
has been stepping up
to rescue and deliver
more food to meet the increased
need in New York City.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands.
We love you.